hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
morgen ist silvester und ich habe mir
gedacht ich zeige euch nochmal eine ganz
schnelle und einfache fingerfood idee
eine lastminute fingerfood idee denn das
konzept was ich jetzt mache geht ganz
schnell
ich mache heute blätterteig stangen
einmal gefüllt mit look also was wenn
murat und einmal gefüllt mit feta und
mit spinat also eher was für mich und
ich überraschend morawitz damit das
rezept geht nämlich superschnell und der
murat ist nämlich gerade weg gefahren um
von mir ab meiner mama abzuholen
also würde ich sagen starten wir direkt
ich brauche dafür zwei rollen
blätterteig den habe ich das ein
kühlfach hier habe ich 200 gramm spinat
200 gramm feta-käse 250 gramm frischkäse
200 käse und 150 gramm
ich starte jetzt zuerst mit dem spinat
den muss nämlich vorbereiten
das ist schon gewaschen und den schneide
ich jetzt ein bisschen klein und es
sieht noch ganz viel spinat aus aber ich
werde ihnen gleich mit heißem wasser
übergießen und dann fällt da in sich
zusammen
jetzt überlege sich dann spinat mit
heißem wasser
und den lasse jetzt einfach kurz stehen
damit ein bisschen zusammenfallen kann
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die andere füllung vorbereiten und
zwar das foto das muss ich jetzt nämlich
kurz klein schneiden
jetzt habe ich hier bereits den
blätterteig ausgerollt und bestreichen
jetzt mit frischkäse und da könnten wir
zum beispiel auch im kreuther frischkäse
benutzen
da streue ich jetzt den käse drauf
das produkt hin
jetzt würde ich normalerweise einfach
die seite drauf klappen aber mir gerade
eingefallen ich mache lieber die
doppelte menge und bestreicht jetzt
alles komplett weil ich dort kommt mit
ein bisschen hunger nach hause
jetzt kommt die zweite rolle drauf
jetzt halte ich den tag einmal und
schneidet dann stangen in der breite von
ungefähr zwei zentimeter zu
jetzt werden die stangen einfach nur
noch gezwirbelt und dann können dass sie
direkt auf einem blech legen
die subtile backe ich jetzt schon mal im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
und unterhitze für etwa zwölf bis 15
minuten und in der zeit kann ich schon
mal die spielanteile zu bereiten
jetzt kenne ich den spinat abgießen und
dann noch ausdrücken
jetzt bereite ich noch die spinat
füllung zu dafür gebe ich jetzt den
schafskäse da noch ein
und da mache ich jetzt so eine pasta so
dass ich sie einfach gleich drauf
streichen kann wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr das auch mit dem foto zu machen also
der frischkäse butter käse und zog
einfach miteinander pariert der flug war
murat das herz aber da kann man sogar
operieren
es gebe ich alle zutaten da rein und
dann wird es einfach bei mixed
die
ich würde jetzt die füllung ich hätte es
jetzt auch beide institute teilen machen
können da wird über alles vergessen
wobei ich das foto zeigt nur mit oregano
und mönche zum beispiel kürzen wird hier
gebe ich jetzt noch besser mit rein dass
ich weg weil es schon 20 genug ist also
ihr müsst einfach mal abschmecken
ich habe mir den feta käse drin ich gebe
ich auch ein bisschen oregano und ein
bisschen mit rein
jetzt kann ich die füllung einfach drauf
streichen mit dem zweiten blätterteig
belegen und auch klein schneiden uns
wehren
ich bin jetzt fertig wenn der rat ist
jetzt mittlerweile auch da und was soll
ich sagen eigentlich keine große
überraschung mehr weil du hast ja schon
wenn es zu job gerochen also geht die
haustür eingegangen wahnsinn ich habe
geduld paradies ich finde dass die
stangen richtig hübsch aussehen also
kannst du mit diesem zwiebel drin
und jetzt vor allem so bunt gemischt
spinat und so richtig sagst du probieren
und ich bin's als fingerfood idee echt
super und für samira habe ich welche mit
nutella gemacht die sind jetzt noch zwei
drei minuten im backofen die bekommt sie
dann nämlich auch branche schmeckt wie
große mit su drin wahnsinn
ja ich glaube wir sind sofort weg glaube
ich auch ich habe eine extra große
passion gemacht ja noch als ding
vielleicht noch den händen sour cream
tipp vielleicht noch ich mein passen
wird es gut aber dann hat man halt noch
mal fertig meine szene jetzt gehaltvoll
genug wurde aber es wird schon mal im
jahr sündigen denn dann könnten wir
natürlich machen
also ich finde es eine ganz tolle idee
vor allem bin ich noch nicht wisst was
ihr morgen abend machen wollt das ist
eine ganz schnelle idee ihr könnt die
vegetarisch machen oder auch mit fleisch
bildung machen und wirklich abwandeln
wie ihr möchtet
also da kann man wirklich alles mögliche
machen mein favorit in dem ich bin auf
und ich glaube dein favorit oder für ein
stimmiges bild auch genauso immer
schwierig zu trocken gegangen ich nicht
möglich mehr aber die kommen sind alles
klar und die urteile sind natürlich auch
gleich weil ich hab mir auch gleich noch
mal
und jetzt auch das rezept gerne
nachlesen auch salehs - blog.de wir
fahren wirklich nicht viele zutaten und
ich hab jetzt an zubereitungszeit etwa
zehn minuten pro sorte gebraucht also
geht wirklich ratzfatz und die sind ganz
schnell fertig und genauso schnell
wieder auf wozu also bis zum nächsten
mal und viel spaß gemacht es noch
wahnsinn das kann schon was bist du dein
letzter kraft in alte jahr sage ich
tschüss
wenn wir in der 5
länger
nein
lecker